scientists think they've made the first
measurements from the cosmic dawn the
period in the universe's history when
the first stars began to shine but how
can scientists study something that
happened more than thirteen and a half
billion years ago well to understand
that you need to start with hydrogen
hydrogen is a cosmologists best friend
they use it to study everything you see
a quirk of hydrogen is that it can emit
photons as it switches between states
specifically photons with a wavelength
at around 21 centimeters when
astronomers point radio telescopes at
the sky they see a mess of different
radio waves but nestled in there is
always that 21 centimeter line these
emissions from hydrogen have helped
scientists to map the universe it's how
they discovered that we're sitting in a
huge spiral-shaped galaxy the Milky Way
but hydrogen isn't just useful for
studying the universe today right after
the Big Bang the universe was a dark
soup of electrons and protons the
particles soon clumped together as
hydrogen and after hundreds of millions
of years
hydrogen collected into stars generating
light cosmologists called this the
cosmic dawn that primordial light is
hard to see with a telescope because the
tiny amounts of light made by the first
stars would be extremely faint so
scientists have taken a slightly
different tack you see when that light
was first created it changed everything
including the hydrogen itself crucially
making it able to absorb radiation at
its favorite 21 centimeter line with
this in mind rather than look for
emission from hydrogen cosmologists have
looked instead for its absorption they
turned to the Cosmic Microwave
Background the mass of radiation left
over from the Big Bang in theory the
moment light hit that early hydrogen it
would have started absorbing this
radiation and that should have left a
blip in the CMB
and that after decades of scouring for
evidence from this time and two years of
verification is what cosmologists have
found but here's where it gets
interesting
the signal they found is not at 21
centimeters anymore because space itself
is expanding that line has stretched
over time which is handy for us because
the amount of stretching the wavelength
for light is it now tells us how long
the light has traveled and so when those
stars formed finally this allows
scientists to put some dates to the
beginning of the cosmic dawn but that is
nor well the time the first stars formed
seems about right
the signal is way bigger than
cosmologists predicted a lot more
radiation was absorbed from this cosmic
microwave background that makes sense
given what we know so far about the
early universe something doesn't add up
and one tantalizing possibility is that
we may be seeing the influence of dark
matter now this is far from confirmed
but if true it would give us a wealth of
information about Dark Matters
properties and where to look for it so
this little blip could not only give us
a snapshot of the first stars but it
could be the key to unlocking one of the
biggest mysteries in physics